Continuing in Al-Wajiz
in the chapter in the book of
purification
yesterday and the day before we
discussed sunan al-fitra, the ways of
al-fitra with respect to personal
hygiene. Now, the author is going to
he mentioned the narrations that listed
those things in quick succession.
So, he mentions the narration of five
things are from the fitra. He then
mentions the narration of 10 things are
of the fitra. And now he will go into
each of them individually, right? And
give some
narrations and context with respect
to each of them individually. The first
of these things that he mentions is
al-khitan.
Al-khitan.
Now, before we begin this, I want to
mention something and that is
if you were around in the '90s
if you were around in the '90s and the
early 2000s,
you'll remember
when the Muslimin
went in the Western media from being
mujahideen freedom fighters to
terrorists, if you remember that, right?
In the '80s during the
expansion of the
communist
It was Russia, but
at that time, you know, in the early
'80s, it was still the
you know, the
Soviet Union.
And so, they were expanding into parts
of Asia, and
they had tried to invade Afghanistan.
And obviously,
the Western countries, the
capitalist and socialist countries,
didn't that very much. And so, the
Muslimin there
were
used in a proxy war.
and they themselves fought to protect
their own country.
And so, they were mujaheddin.
And
things were normal. As a matter of fact,
in the late '80s and early '90s, there
were places in America here where you
could go
in New York City, or you could actually
go and sign up, right, to be
sent over to Afghanistan to fight
with the mujaheddin. It was totally
normal. And then, whoever survived
and lived from amongst our brothers
and sisters
were put they became the next
enemy. And they went from mujaheddin to
terrorists, right? And they were
pursued. And part of that pursuit, and
part of a lot of that
a lot of that propaganda
revolved around going to very poor,
very war-torn
Muslim places, not even countries,
places, where the people there are
either being governed by extremists like
out of innately extreme or cults or
warlords and had little to do with
Islam.
And filming them and taking this as a
representation of Islam and Islamic
scholarship. Why am I mentioning this
now? Well, part of that, if you
remember,
was the circumcision.
The circumcision of girls in Somalia at
the time. It was the circumcision of
girls in Somalia and
parts of Africa where it was like
you know, these these terrible people,
they are mutilating the genitals of
their daughters and so on and so forth.
And so, many Muslims are unaware that
circumcision is not just for men, not
just for boys. It is for girls as well.
However, there's a right way for it to
be done and there's a wrong way. Just as
circumcision for a boy, there is a right
way for it to be done and there is a
wrong way. And circumcision for women or
for girls is very different than it is
for boys. It's for different reasons and
it's a different part of the genitalia.
But both are part of the Sunnah. Both
have been narrated from the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam in spite of a
lot of this propaganda. So, let us let
[Arabic recitation]
the author tells us, he says, "And
circumcision is obligatory
for both male and female, men and
women." And this is the opinion that the
author has chosen.
the scholars have differed, the
scholars have differed greatly on this.
And this is
the opinion that many of the scholars
of Hadith and the Muhaddithin have held.
However, it is not as strong as an
opinion. And the correct opinion
and the stronger opinion, it is
obligatory for men and it is preferable
for women. And the evidences that he
cites, we will discuss why that is,
inshallah. He says, "And the reason that
it is obligatory is that it is part of
the rights of Islam." Meaning, it's one
of the defining characteristics,
defining practices of Islam. And the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam was
narrated to have said to a man who
accepted Islam,
"Go and remove the hair of disbelief
from upon your body and get circumcised
and circumcise
yourself."
So, the hair of disbelief, meaning
to
the armpits, the
the
private parts, the pubic hair, and to
cut or even trim entirely the
head.
He didn't say this to every person that
accepted Islam. He said it to this man.
So, it's very possible that this man had
hair that was very long or very similar
to
a type of hair
that only Kuffar have. In our common
day,
we could liken this to something akin to
dreadlocks. If a person had dreadlocks,
this is something which is specific to
non-Muslims. As a matter of fact, it is
a religious right of certain fringe
groups. And so, he said to him, "Go and
remove the hair of disbelief from your
body and become circumcised." This was
narrated by Abu Dawud and Al-Bayhaqi.
Now, notice
that he is going to mention for us the
first evidence that
Al-Khitān
circumcision is obligatory for men and
women. Let's debate this
this
Let us debate this opinion.
[Silence]
He says, "On the authority of Abu
Hurayrah,
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
that Ibrahim,
the beloved of Rahman,
Khalil Rahman
circumcised himself after the age of 80
years old.
Right?
Why did he wait so long? Because that
was when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
commanded him to do it.
He was commanded
at that age, and so he circumcised
himself
alaihis salatu wasallam.
Now,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then says to
his prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam, "Then we revealed to you
that you should follow the religion of
Ibrahim."
And that is a general rule. Anything
that is narrated to be of the actions or
practices of Ibrahim alaihis salaam,
as long as it doesn't clash with
something that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam has commanded,
then it is automatically part of our
sunnah as well, because
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
in a number of verses, but in this
particular verse that he cites, verse
123,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in the
closing verses of Surat An-Nahl, which
translate to
"And we then
sent revelation to you, O Muhammad,
commanding you to follow the way and the
path of Ibrahim."
So, anything that Ibrahim did,
our prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
did. And that is why we are upon the
millah of Ibrahim.
So, what is the connection here? Well,
anything that our prophet tells us
Ibrahim did, Ibrahim said, Ibrahim would
do, Ibrahim wouldn't do,
automatically falls into the generality
of
Ibrahim.
Follow the way of Ibrahim.
Unless otherwise stated, unless the
prophet
was selling says or does something to
the contrary.
So, part of that is
circumcision. This isn't just a story
that the prophet tells us that Ibrahim
circumcised himself after the age of
80. This is a command, right?
However,
is this a strong enough evidence that
women
are obligated to be circumcised as well?
What do you think?
Why?
[Silence]
Okay. You wanted to say something?
[Arabic recitation]
more or less that is correct.
So, the narration tells us that Ibrahim
circumcised himself after the age of 80.
Now, this is
a bit difficult for someone who's that
old and to do it himself,
right? So, we know that this is
obligatory
because something that is not obligatory
and that is that difficult would not be
commanded in that way. So, it's
obligatory.
But he had a wife, too, right? And he
also had a concubine.
And there's no mention of them being
circumcised, correct?
So, we can almost be positive that his
wife and his concubine, especially that
they were from two different places,
that they were not circumcised.
So, where is the evidence for his wife
or his concubine being circumcised? The
answer is
it it is not there. And
for this to be a strong enough evidence
for men and women, we would have to find
Ibrahim and his wife both were
circumcised at the age of 80. Okay,
that that would be a clear evidence. But
when it's just Ibrahim alayhis salaam,
and so we go back to what the majority
of the scholars mention, and that is
that
circumcision for men is obligatory,
circumcision for women is
preferable, mustahab.
Right? For men, it is obligatory. For
women, it is what? Mustahab.
And not only are we drawing that from
the evidences,
but we're also drawing that from the
reason
or the purpose that circumcision
that circumcision is for, the purpose
that it is done for for men and women.
Circumcision for men
is for hygiene. Circumcision for women
is for is to help curb sexual drive. And
we will discuss this tomorrow, inshallah
ta'ala. So, they are fundamentally at
their core two very different things
and so for this reason we cannot give
them the exact same ruling
and we will discuss this in more detail
tomorrow in sha'a Allah